(plate clinks)
(playful music)
(speaks in Korean)
(car honks)
(robot talks)
(object drops)
- Hey, big day this month, right?
- Oh, yeah.
Let me check my calendar.
(metal drops)
Uhmm.
- Do you smoke?
- Is that Kay Barbecue?
(car honks)
This smells good.
(crank turns)
(car honks)
(sheep cries)
(object drops)
Oh no.
- So, yeah.
I'm really into Aegis.
(objects drop)
(speaks gibberish)
(whistles)
- So fine.
(glass shatters)
(bleep)
(cat meows)
- Hey, Ma.
I got the message.
(pops)
- ing hot.
Ahh!
- But where are you really from?
(car honks)
- So cute!
(speaks in Japanese)
(metal clinks)
- You.
- 'Sup, Chris.
- What the
(plate shatters)
- Hey, Michelle.
- Seriously?
(metal clinks)
- Hey, wait a minute.
Remember Avatar: The Last Airbender movie?
(duck quacks)
- Why do you ruin my Monday?
- (laughs)
(playful music)
(squeaks)
(cat meows)
- Why am I even watching this?
I don't even like it.